anyone who's ever visited a Sandy Ocean
Beach has certainly noticed the ripples
of sand created by the flow of water
which later become exposed with the
coming and going of the tide these
Landmark current ripples are of course
quite small measuring in merely inches
and although they are not something that
we would typically pay much attention to
they are nonetheless the result and
obvious evidence that the ocean had once
flowed over the area however what I'm
about to share with you is so
astonishing that by the end of this
video you will never think of these
ripples of sand or the entire Sahara
desert in the same way ever again you
see if a typical tidal current that is
just a few feet or meters in depth can
create sand ripples that are measured in
merely inches then what on Earth would
it take to create ripples that are yet
this more than a mile apart and
literally hundreds of feet tall that's
right so large in fact that they can
only be truly appreciated from far above
with the use of satellite imagery what
you're seeing here is more than 200
miles Inland off the Atlantic coast of
Mauritania in the western Sahara Desert
of Africa smack dab in the middle of a
remote region of the Sahara that has
inexplicably massive amounts of water
erosion that is so extreme that the
striations can clearly be seen from
space and upon a closer look you can see
the same Landmark current ripples that
we observe on most any beach however
instead of being measured in mere inches
or feet these ripples are so
extraordinarily enormous that they are
measurable in miles that's right in fact
the smallest of these ripples are closer
to three quarters of a mile apart with
many right in the neighborhood of a mile
with some of the largest measuring 6300
feet apart which equates to one and a
quarter mile and just a quick reminder
that one mile equates to
5280 feet or some 1600 meters now real
quick to put this into perspective let
me show you a short video clip that went
viral a few years ago when Randall
Carlson and Graham Hancock appeared on
The Joe Rogan Experience Podcast and
shared the enormous current ripples in
the middle of Montana that were created
by the catastrophic flooding that
occurred during the rapid melting of the
North American ice shelf at the end of
the last ice age just listen to what
they have to say here rippled landscape
that looks exactly like the beach looks
yeah keep coming around that's the thing
it's fractal because this this is the
whole mystery of this that this happens
at a scale of inches on beaches and a
scale of hundreds of feet here and
there's a farmhouse you see The
Farmhouse there
now those ripples are the tallest ones
are about the height of a five-story
building
whoa like 70 feet or something like that
50 feet okay so that's those are 50 feet
high okay let's pause again look at this
this is crazy this is totally crazy this
is one of the craziest things you'll
ever see this is these ripples repeated
ripples in an area where there's nothing
else like it the closest the closest we
can get to it is is a tsunami but even
there you got a picture of the tsunamis
that we've experienced in the last
decade and a half and you know in in
Indonesia and Japan when they made
landfall those tsunamis were roughly
between 20 and 50 feet depending on
where you were relative to the to the
oncoming wave and how far distant you
were from it hear what you have to
visualize is a tsunami sweeping over the
land that's over a thousand feet deep
that's that's what happened here and we
know that because we can trace the the
high water marks on the hillsides are
clearly left the high water marks are
clearly etched into the into the
hillsides pretty mind-blowing right so
now the question becomes that if
Landmark current ripples that are 50
feet tall and just shy of 300 feet apart
as I measured on Google Earth and were
created by a flow of water that was one
thousand feet deep then what on Earth
happened to create ripples that are 200
feet tall and again exceeding more than
a mile apart but if that isn't
incredible enough this is where things
become spectacularly strange as I'm
about to share with you three pieces of
evidence that are so unbelievably
compelling that they cooperate that this
water erosion occurred in just the last
11 to 12 000 years now real quick before
I show you that let's first be clear
these are not sand dunes they are indeed
ripples created by force sources of
flowing water just like we see at the
beach for example let's take a look at
what actual confirmed sand dunes look
like in comparison and there is perhaps
no better example than the sand dunes of
Namibia which rank among the largest
Dunes found anywhere on Earth and are
conveniently geographically located
right at the coastline of the Atlantic
Ocean which provides us a fantastically
ideal comparison as we're able to
observe sand dunes and ocean current
ripples at the same location and
although these massive sand dunes can
give a similar appearance to The
Landmark current ripples upon a closer
inspection you can certainly distinguish
the difference in that they are made
entirely of sand whereas in the Sahara
you have the visible marks of water
eroded Bedrock that have taken the shape
of current ripples in the same way that
we see at the beach these massive
current ripples have been confirmed by
subject matter experts such as Randall
Carlson and you know I can't help be
reminded of what I noticed not long ago
while taking a walk along an irrigation
canal not far from where I live you can
see the same water-induced current
ripples of sand at the bottom that were
created by the canals flowing water
those are not sand dunes so when we
consider that the Sahara is clearly
covered in vast measures of water
erosion the next question becomes how
and when did this happen now this first
look at the strange abundance of salt
located throughout the Sahara Desert
which I have discussed previously many
people are not aware that the Sahara
provides vast amounts of salt trade
throughout the region this is something
that is widely documented and I have
argued that the fact that this salt sits
on top of the current ripples is
suggestive evidence that the ocean had
flowed over the region and the existing
salt is the remnants of evaporated
seawater that had settled here for
example high concentrations of salt are
found in the region surrounding
Mauritania specifically such as the
sepha salt mine in the capital of New Ox
shot located right at the coast and can
be seen as white blemishes from
satellite imagery all of that is salt
and I have of course shared the nature
of salt found within the Rishad
structure and the areas with the most of
it are all at the lowest elevations thus
suggesting that seawater had settled and
eventually evaporated here another great
example of this can be found as far away
as the Eastern Sahara where we have a
nearly 100 mile wide patch of surface
salt you can take it upon yourself to go
to Google Earth and can view the changes
of elevation with your computer's mouse
cursor and see firsthand that this salt
patch sits on a depression and is at a
lower elevation by a few hundred feet
than the entire surrounding area and
when you take into account that this is
in the midst of a clear path of massive
water erosion as you can see in the
striations it becomes obvious that
seawater had indeed settled here
so hold that thought as the next two
pieces of evidence that I'm going to
share are a total Game Changer in
substantiating that this flooding
erosion happened within the last 11 to
12 000 years because here's the thing
many will dismiss all this water erosion
as being related to what's referred to
as the trans-saharan Seaway which was
said to exist approximately 56 to 66
million years ago in fact most
scientific estimates lazily estimate
that this was likely between 50 and 100
million years ago which let's be real is
a ridiculously large ballpark range of
an estimate but upon further
investigation you will notice that
nowhere in these studies of the
trans-saharan Seaway does it annotate
that it had flowed over the Western
Sahara Desert it simply shows that it
went South however anyone can jump on
Google Earth and clearly observe that
there is confirmed water erosion over
the exact areas annotated for this
Seaway a but here's the thing the same
water erosion clearly Goes West out to
the Atlantic Ocean as you've already
noticed which bizarrely these recent
studies do not annotate whatsoever which
is why I argue that something else
happened far more recently than the
Saharan Seaway of some 60 million years
ago and this is the part where things
get extraordinarily interesting because
the highest point in the Sahara Desert
is a volcano located in Chad called
emikusi which reaches a height of 11 300
feet at its Caldera and is said to have
been created during an eruption between
two and three million years ago however
the last known lava flow occurred at the
south end of emikusi approximately
twelve thousand years ago give or take
but notice how it is positioned directly
along the path of the catastrophic water
erosion in fact it appears to cut right
through this twelve thousand year old
lava flow right there at the South you
can literally noticed the line of a path
that the water took and essentially
eroded and erased the portions of that
lava flow which means that that flooding
would have had to have happened after
that flow of lava that is by the way
scientifically documented to have
occurred approximately 12 000 years ago
and not only that this white blemish
within emikusi's Caldera at 11 000 feet
in elevation is not snow it's salt salt
that is said to be the remains of an
ancient Lake that disappeared just
thousands of years ago gee where on
Earth did that saltwater lake come from
as obviously it would have had to have
formed after the volcano's original
eruption and creation which again was
some 2-3 million years ago which is way
more recent than the 60 or so million
years ago that's been claimed for the
last time that water flowed through the
Sahara which tells us that something
else something separate happened to the
Sahara Desert far more recently that has
seemingly evaded the scientific
Community but if that isn't Smoking Gun
evidence enough wait until you hear my
third and final point of scientific
evidence which is nothing short of
incredible
if there had been catastrophic ocean
flooding through the Sahara then it
would certainly have pushed unfathomable
amounts of debris and sediment out to
the Atlantic Ocean as that appears to be
the path and flow of the flooding so I
did some investigating and I came across
something very very interesting which is
a study of the mapping of seafloor
morphology off the coast of Mauritania
and get this there is a massive seafloor
side called the Mauritania slide which I
estimate from The Legend on the lower
right corner is at least 120 miles wide
when going from north to south and
likely more than 400 miles wide when
measuring from east to west make no
mistake this sea floor slide is
unbelievably massive and not only that
the seafloor sediment consists of
stacked debris that measures at least a
couple thousand meters or just over a
mile in depth a truly astronomical
amount of sediment and this is the part
that makes it so astoundingly
interesting which is the fact that the
researchers of this study estimate that
it is approximately 11
000 years old and get this is likely to
have been created by a tsunami the
evidence is simply overwhelming that
something extreme happened to the Sahara
Desert far more recently than anyone
thought possible and the evidence is
there for all who have eyes to see or at
least go looking for the information and
considering that it's been discovered in
just the last several years that the
Sahara Desert is not actually millions
of years old as previously thought it
was actually a lush green Tropical
Paradise with some of the largest
freshwater lakes ever known to have
existed and also consisted of a massive
network of rivers until something
happened between eleven thousand and
five thousand years ago to turn it into
the massive Continental sized desert as
we know it today
so it seems reasonable to surmise that
all of this is likely related to the
same event or if nothing else is a
missing piece of the puzzle so this
brings me back to the question which is
what on Earth would have had to have
happened to create a tidal wave or a
tsunami over the Sahara to create
current ripples that are so
exponentially larger than the already
massive ones found at Camas Prairie in
Montana leave a comment and share your
thoughts as this is something that
should be worth a video in itself now
with all of this said my next video is
going to be on the Lost ancient city of
Atlantis as it ties into the Rishad
structure or eye of the Sahara which was
supposed to be this video but the video
got so long with all the different
information that I've been building and
I realized that just proving that the
ocean had blown through the Sahara far
more recently was taking too much time
up in that video but I've come across
several pieces of amazing information
that I think is going to wow people and
provides an unbelievably more compelling
argument that the rishat structure is
indeed the Lost ancient capital city of
Atlantis or at least the most likely
location so that video will be out in
approximately the next week and a half
it's basically done and I think people
are going to be surprised by some of the
details that are being added into this
so all that said my name is Jimmy
corsetti my channel is called bright
Insight leave a comment and share all
your thoughts and everything that's
discussed in this I mean between the
water erosion going right through that
volcano between the fact that salt is on
top of all of this these current Ripples
and the sand itself throughout the
Sahara and not to mention the 11 000
year
tsunami of sediment off the coast of
Mauritania clearly something happened
here within that period of time and it
makes me wonder where is the scientific
and academic community and all this
I feel like these dots should have been
connected much sooner based on a lot of
this data existing for several years
already but that aside I'll close it up
again my name is Jimmy stay tuned for
that next Atlantis video real soon take
care everybody